[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7 8
j'espère que le weekend prolongé a été
bon on démarre la soirée ensemble avec
de l'actualité des infos pratiques et
des idées de sortie voici les titres de
ce mardi 2 mai
regain de colère face au projet de
prison à Magnanville alors que l'État
vient de confirmer la construction d'une
maison d'arrêt de 700 places d'ici 2027
dans la commune les élus locaux
dénoncent cette décision en cause
notamment la proximité du futur
établissement avec un quartier
résidentiel et un lycée Bruno milliennes
député de la 9ème circonscription des
Yvelines et Michel Lebouc maire de
Magnanville sont nos invités et puis
avec l'arrivée des beaux jours n'est-il
pas le moment d'aller flâner au château
de Breteuil durant toute l'année et les
vacances scolaires l'établissement
propose une multitude d'activités et
skate game escrime ou encore
reconstitution historique Jean-Emmanuel
Charo administrateur du château de
Breteuil et là pour nous en parler et
puis elle était considérée comme l'une
des figures emblématiques du sport ini
montant ce dimanche un hommage a été
rendu à Annie Couton l'ex-présidente du
club le Cougar de Montigny-le-Bretonneux
des moments lui ont été consacrés retour
sur cette journée spéciale dans cette
édition
et puis tout au long de cette émission
également nous serons accompagnés par
des invités en plateau mais aussi à
distance et tout d'abord je salue à
distance nos invités Bruno millienne
bonsoir donc vous êtes le début vous
êtes le député de la 9e circonscription
des Yvelines et à distance également à
Michel le bouc bonsoir
bonsoir alors vous êtes le maire de
Magnanville et avec vous on parlera
justement du projet de l'État
d'installer une prison d'ici à 2027 à
Magnanville et en plateau avec nous
également Michael el mis Doro bonsoir
alors vous êtes journaliste sport de TV
78 et vous avez pour habitude de nous
faire un retour des résultats sportifs
du week-end le lundi mais avec le 1er
mai c'est aujourd'hui que vous nous
faites un récap exactement on va parler
notamment de la brillante qualification
de plaisir c'était en barrage de fédéral
2 ils ont gagné contre Saint-Claude ce
week-end on parlerons également de la
défaite de Versailles eux sont éliminés
en fédéral 2 ils ne pourront pas aller
plus loin on parlera également du Racing
Club de France qui a fait match nul
contre Rouen 0 à 0 c'était à Versailles
il nous reviendront également sur la
défaite des Templiers d'Élancourt en
football américain
en face de vous une autre journaliste de
la rédaction c'est une Charles bonsoir
bonsoir alors avec vous nous ferons le
point sur l'actualité à Ret dans les
Yvelines et dans cette édition également
on parlera de motocross avec un jeune
yvelinois Tom Smith il est pilote et là
aujourd'hui le statut sportif espoir
national attribué par le ministère des
Sports et puis comme chaque maladie
chaque mardi on recevra également
Véronique Ithurbide chronique chez tv78
elle viendra nous parler des
informations insolites dans les Yvelines
mais juste avant je vous propose de
jeter un œil aux prévisions météo de
demain
et c'est avec un temps ensoleillé que
vous démarrez la journée mercredi matin
les températures sont de 9 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie ou dans et Rambouillet
et 10 degrés à Versailles dans
l'après-midi le soleil restera au beau
fixe dans tout le département au niveau
des températures il fera 18 degrés à
Versailles et Mantes-la-Jolie et 19
degrés à Houdan et Rambouillet et demain
nous fêterons la Saint Philippe et la
Saint-Jacques le point tout de suite sur
les actualités du jour dans les Yvelines
et on commence avec cette information
Céline l'actionnaire du FC Versailles
Christophe petit à démenti les
difficultés financières du club oui on
le disait en difficulté avec même
impossible dépôt de bilan et bien les
deux actionnaires du club de Versailles
Christophe petit et Julien ridon ont
démenti ses informations à nos confrères
du Parisien plusieurs de leurs
adversaires avancées notamment des
problèmes financiers chez le groupe
immobilier City appartenant aux deux
actionnaires et des pertes financières
de plusieurs millions d'euros au sein du
club de Versailles Christophe petit a
réfuté ses informations selon lui le
club ne serait pas en danger il ne
s'oppose cependant pas l'idée d'ouvrir
progressivement le capital en vue de la
prochaine saison prochaine saison qui
pourrait d'ailleurs déjà se jouer ce
soir Versailles disputera un derby
important face au Red Star et les
villages fondations Paris Saint-Germain
reviennent dans les Yvelines mais un
événement soutenu par le département qui
permet d'utiliser le sport et ses
valeurs comme levier d'apprentissage
d'épanouissement et de solidarité la
journée permet à plusieurs enfants et
leur famille de profiter de diverses
activités sportives éducatives et
citoyennes gratuitement on retrouve par
exemple la sensibilisation à l'écologie
au handicap des quizz des ateliers
autour du club du PSG et son histoire et
bien sûr du sport alors demain mercredi
3 mai le village sera au parc de la
coulée verte à Oinville-sur-Montcient le
jeudi 4 au parking du stade de
Saint-Rémy-lès-Chevreuse et le vendredi
5 mai au 1000 clubs de Septeuil les
activités sont organisées de 14 heures à
17h30 et un Ivy noix a effectué un
véritable exploit ce week-end 200 km
parcourus en moins de 24 heures et oui
Régine on poursuit encore avec du sport
mais cette fois-ci autour d'une prouesse
physique Florian sapeur-pompier
volontaire d'Aubergenville a pris le
départ dimanche à 7h d'une course à pied
de 200 km autour de la caserne son
objectif était de terminer en moins de
24 heures et c'est défi réussi il est
arrivé hier matin après 21h d'exercice
alors la course a réuni beaucoup de
monde puisque plusieurs de ses collègues
se sont relayés pour parcourir quelques
kilomètres avec une initiative sous fond
de solidarité Florian récoltait
plusieurs milliers d'euros de fonds pour
les œuvres des pupilles une association
qui vient notamment en aide aux
orphelins des combattants du feu et la
ville de Saint-Cyr l'école a obtenu une
certification il s'agit précisément de
la certification qualivie une
distinction qui récompense la qualité
des services rendus à la population et
qui salue l'engagement des agents
municipaux elle concerne par exemple les
délai de réponse les suivis dossiers
l'obtention rapide de rendez-vous en
bref tout ce qui concerne l'accueil
physique et téléphonique de l'Hôtel de
Ville l'objectif pour la commune de
Saint-Cyr-l'École c'est bien sûr
d'étendre cette démarche à d'autres
services municipaux la certification est
donnée trois ans et réviser chaque année
et on termine avec cette information un
feu jaune pour les piétons va être
prochainement testé dans civils de
France et oui Régine et Versailles est
l'une d'entre elles alors ce feu jaune
il est similaire au feu orange pour les
voitures il signalera au piéton le
passage à venir au feu rouge alors pas
de traverser au feu jaune mais il
permettra aux piétons déjà engagés de
finir la traversée en toute sécurité ce
feu va donc être testé à Versailles
c'est ce qu'indique un arrêté publié au
Journal officiel et bien merci Céline
pour ces informations dans les Yvelines
et comme d'habitude si vous aussi vous
êtes témoin d'un fait qui vous a marqué
près de chez vous n'hésitez surtout pas
nous le partager sur les réseaux sociaux
avec le hashtag 7 8 news
et on en parlait tout à l'heure dans les
titres la construction d'une maison
d'arrêt fait débat après de multiples
réunions pour décider de l'emplacement
de ces dernières la pige agence publique
pour l'immobilier de la justice a rendu
son verdict et maintient son projet
d'installer une maison d'arrêt de 700
places à Magnanville d'ici 2027 alors
pour en parler avec nous Bruno millienne
député de la 9ème circonscription des
Yvelines et Michel le bouc maire de
Magnanville merci à vous deux d'avoir
accepté notre invitation alors comme
vous êtes justement tous les deux à
distance veillez s'il vous plaît du coup
à respecter les prises de parole de
chacun et à ne pas vous interrompre et
je démarre avec vous Michel lebook donc
vous êtes contre ce projet de prison
quelles sont les raisons de cette
opposition
déjà une petite précision vous avez dit
tout à l'heure c'était décidé pour
l'instant il n'y a aucune décision je
tenais par rapport à vos auditeurs à le
préciser aucune décision de prise la
pige donc lors du dernier COPIL c'est un
copie le politique avec le préfet autour
du préfet les parlementaires moi-même et
d'autres maires
à réaffirmer je dirais suite à mes
propositions à nos propositions d'études
de sylvt alternatif que Magnanville
était le meilleur site voilà mais aucune
décision vous savez que la pige fait des
propositions copiles et c'est le préfet
des Yvelines qui rendra sa copie auprès
du ministre de la Justice je tenais à
faire cette précision en introduction
bah pourquoi je suis content déjà pour
préciser et et Bruno millième le sait
c'est que moi déjà je ne suis pas contre
la construction de place de prison
supplémentaires étant donné que le
projet 15000 places de prison
supplémentaires
du président de la République juillet
associe et je l'avais dit au ministre de
la Justice à l'époque parce que je pense
qu'il y a une surpopulation c'est pas
que je pense c'est que les retours qu'on
a il y a une surpopulation carcérale on
a été attrapé aussi par la Cour
européenne de justice et puis et puis
l'humain aussi je pense que on peut pas
laisser des gens emprisonnés dans dans
10 mètres carrés à une dizaine de de
prisonniers voilà alors oui je suis pour
la construction de place de prison
supplémentaires par contre le site de
nianville Jamy oppose déjà premièrement
pourquoi parce que je pense que
Magnanville c'est la contradiction des
positions de l'État là où on nous parle
le président de la République de 0
artificialisation des sols on évoque la
possibilité de prendre 20 hectares de
terres agricoles sur les terrains de de
Magnanville là on nous parle de coup
carbone vous savez que Magnanville c'est
pas proche du tribunal de Versailles on
va faire des allers-retours parce que
les gens c'est une maison d'arrêt donc
les gens ne sont pas jugés ils iront au
tribunal de Versailles je sais pas
combien de véhicules jours ça va
impacter mais c'est énorme et on nous
parle de 0 carbone et alors qu'on est au
plus loin du tribunal de Versailles en
ville c'est la fin de la région de
France comme vous le savez et puis je
parle pas de l'ensemble des incohérences
que j'ai déjà porté ça serait trop long
à le dire je vais essayer de faire court
mais sur les questions de mobilité sur
les positions de proximité des
habitations on construit cette cette
maison d'arrêt à 150 mètres d'habitation
à 150 mètres de deux lycée dont un des
plus gros lycées de la région nantaise
1300 élèves sans compter les questions
d'assainissement de ruissellement des
eaux voilà donc oui je m'y oppose et
j'ai dans ce cadre-là
suite à la proposition du préfet fait
des propositions de sites alternatives
on nous a donné à peu près deux mois et
demi excusez-moi Michel Lebouc on va
justement y revenir
voilà
mais très bien les justement alors Bruno
Miguel qu'est-ce que vous avez à
répondre à cela pourquoi selon vous
magnez en ville et la commune la plus
adaptée pour accueillir cette maison
d'arrêt
je suis pas en mesure de juger de la
décision que prend la pige vous savez
que la construction d'une prison en
l'occurrence une maison d'arrêt c'est un
petit peu différent
la construction d'une maison d'arrêt
répond à des normes de sécurité et de
positionnement et d'emplacement de
l'endroit où elle doit être posée très
très précis pour des raisons de sécurité
justement donc on peut pas faire
n'importe quoi moi je le remercie Michel
Leboucq parce que après on démarre un
petit peu difficile des copilotages il a
essayé avec les élus locaux de proposer
des situations
alternatives un magnet en ville et lors
du dernier COPIL la pige a considérer
pour des raisons qui ne semblent moins
valables au regard des contraintes
qu'ils ont ils ont décidé d'écarter
toutes les propositions qui ont été
faites alors après je suis pas non plus
ravi honnêtement que cette prison
s'installe à Magnanville Michel je n'ai
jamais dit ça je dis simplement que dans
une politique
judiciaire où il faut faire attention à
surpopulation carcérale et on la verra
plus ou la prison de Bois-d'Arcy est en
surpopulation à 161% il faut qu'on fasse
quelque chose il semblerait je suis pas
leur place mais il semblerait que
trouver un endroit plus près de
Versailles ça semble difficile il y
avait eu la piste des friches
industrielles ou des friches
commerciales mais beaucoup d'entre elles
sont déjà occupées par des par des
projets à la fois commerciaux et
industriels et de toute façon n'aurait
pas eu la surface nécessaire donc les 20
les 20 hectares que ce soit moins en
ville ou ailleurs malheureusement je dis
bien malheureusement et dans le cadre
d'élaboration de nouvelles maisons
d'arrêt ou de nouvelles prisons souvent
on prend sur les cases agricoles bon ça
c'est un premier fait le deuxième fait
et là où je rejoins Michel et je l'ai
signalé d'ailleurs à la pile je vais
tout à fait honnête il reste que deux
sites en fait valable pour la pige le
premier qui me paraît un petit peu
compliqué quand même parce
qu'effectivement 150 mètres des
habitants à proximité immédiate du lycée
Léopold Sédar Senghor ça n'a pas ça n'a
pas ma préférence pour être honnête il y
a un deuxième site qui est un petit peu
plus loin qui a été un kilomètre de
Magnanville qui est un peu plus près de
soins donc qui posera d'autres problèmes
mais s'il n'y avait pas d'autres
endroits où mettre à la limite je
préférais ce site là même si
effectivement il a subjectif une
rectification du Drif et ça ça risque
d'être compliqué d'autant que d'autant
que j'ai appris entre le copilotage que
nous avons eu la dernière fois et
l'émission d'aujourd'hui que la région
Île-de-France envisagerait un changement
du drift qui interdirait finalement la
construction de toute nouvelle prison
sur la région Île-de-France ce qui me
semble un petit peu fort de café de la
part d'une majorité LR qui a toujours
prôné le plus de prison oui on construit
pas assez de prison et vous ne tiendrez
pas vos objectifs enfin ça c'est à eux
de répondre par la finemative ou non à
ce que je viens de dire mais c'est un
petit bruit qui m'est revenu aux
oreilles dans les derniers jours et je
trouve ça quand même un peu gonflé donc
pour conclure il y a jamais de bonne
solution quand on veut créer une prison
je vous le dis tel que je le pense parce
que où que vous créez la prison de toute
façon les gens vont se poser et c'est
une réaction normale maintenant comme
l'a dit Michel la décision définitive
n'est pas prise il y a encore une
concertation publique qui doit commencer
à l'automne donc les gens sont consultés
et on verra ce qu'il advient après ne
mettons pas la charrue avant
et donc Michel Lebouc vous avez
également adressé une lettre au préfet
des Yvelines mais également au président
de la République Emmanuel Macron à
Elisabeth borne la première ministre et
également ministre de la Justice Eric
Dupont-Moretti où vous listez justement
les contraintes de ce projet est-ce que
vous avez déjà eu des retours
on est dans un climat social que vous
connaissez déjà très compliqué mais oui
je me suis permis d'écrire au président
de la République et de fait à la
première ministre et au ministre de
tutelle pour pour leur indiquer
premièrement que il y avait pour moi
c'est un peu le désaccord que j'ai avec
avec Bruno il y a des friches
industrielles qui existent sur nos
territoires et je pense qu'il faut
regarder le meilleur site moi je le dis
souvent quand les élus
participent on porte beaucoup les élus
de proximité il faut les écouter il faut
travailler avec eux quand ils
participent et c'est pour ça que j'ai
donné mon accord parce que moi je suis
comme Bruno William je ne connais rien
en rien le cahier des charges de la
construction d'une maison d'arrêt ou
d'une prison c'est pas c'est pas mon job
entre guillemets mais au-delà de ça j'ai
fait travailler les services de la
Communauté Urbaine j'ai fait travailler
mes services pour regarder des sites
alternatifs par rapport au cahier des
charges de la pige et donc j'ai fait
aussi et j'ai demandé au service de
travailler les deux options
manières-villoise comme le disait Bruno
millième il y a une option proche des
habitations et du lycée il y a des
options une autre option qui est un peu
plus lointaine pour pas qu'on me taxe de
dire que je cible en dehors de manière
en ville et c'est pas mon style et en
fin de compte ce qu'il en ressort c'est
que sur les sites étudiés Magnanville
les deux options de namurville sont les
sites qui ne correspondent pas ou qui a
eu des charges
je dirais par rapport aux autres sites
et notamment sur des friches
industrielles donc c'est pour ça que
j'interpelle le président de la
République moi je veux bien continuer à
travailler avec les élus de proximité
avec les parlementaires parce que je
pense qu'il y a eu du bon travail de
fait dans nos copines même si on n'était
pas tous d'accord mais ça ça fait partie
aussi de la démocratie on peut pas être
tous d'accord mais dans le même temps
c'est ça j'ai besoin qu'on nous écoute
les élus de proximité parce que c'est la
confiance aussi donner je dirais à nos
habitants qui feront que ce projet là et
comme le immobilier ou qu'il soit de
toute façon il y aura toujours des
mécontents mais essayons de trouver une
entente entre les élus que nous sommes
l'état parce qu'on a besoin de
construire de nouvelles de nouveaux
emplacements de maison d'arrêt et la
population vous le verrez quand la
population a toujours confiance en ces
élus de proximité et c'est ça que je
porte et c'est ça que j'ai porté en
priorité donc pour Rio président de la
République et tout pour tout vous dire
je n'ai toujours pas de réponse ni de la
première ministre ni du président de la
République mais je pense qu'ils vont
m'écrire incessamment sous peu
très bien et justement vous avez
j'imagine mener des consultations
également auprès de la population des
habitants qui est quels sont leurs
retours aujourd'hui quels sont leurs
principales craintes
moi j'ai pas mené de consultation je
salue aussi le travail qui a été réalisé
par l'association tous mobilisés contre
la prison qui était une association qui
s'est montée pendant pendant ces mois là
c'est eux qui ont consultait la
population c'est pas c'est pas mon rôle
mais moi je mon rôle en tant que mère
c'est de d'écouter les gens de recevoir
les gens il est vrai qu'il y a beaucoup
de mécontents plus de mécontents que de
gens contents après je n'ai pas sondé la
population vous savez les sondages je
m'en méfie tout le temps parce que il y
a ceux qui sont éloignés du site qui
pourraient dire bah moi je m'en fous
puis il y a ceux qui sont en proximité
bah eux ça les intéresse plus que les
autres voilà moi je me suis fait ma
position par rapport à la à la au projet
de métape et c'est comme ça que je
travaille et je vais annoncer une
réunion publique j'espère que Bruno y
participera pas pour qu'on puisse se
jeter la pierre aux uns aux autres je
pense que la démocratie en fait partie
j'ai proposé j'ai proposé à l'ensemble
des élus perman parlementaire de faire
une réunion publique dans les jours fin
mai et avec la presse bien entendu vous
serez les bienvenus pour qu'on puisse
échanger avec les populations parce que
ce n'est pas que la population
magnanvilloise qui est touché c'est
l'ensemble de la population du Mantois
je rappelle que le manteau est une une
région quoi après une région mais
sinistré et donc il faut être attentif
aussi à ce qui se passe dans notre belle
région du Mantois voilà alors je
m'adresse maintenant à Bruno millienne
quelle comment est-ce qu'on peut
améliorer le dialogue aujourd'hui et
quels sont les prochaines étapes
alors c'est compliqué parce qu'il faut
il faut faire comprendre aux gens des
choses qui sont assez contre intuitives
en fait si vous interrogez
mais enfin de Bois d'Arcy il vous dira
que les alentours de la prison de
Bois-d'Arcy c'est vraiment la zone la
plus sécurisée finalement de sa ville et
forcément parce qu'il y a énormément de
sécurité autour et que finalement la
présence de cette prison
ne détruit pas du tout la vie autour
bien au contraire mais ça c'est
totalement contre intuitif donc il faut
amener les gens il faut discuter avec
eux leur faire comprendre moi je suis
pas en train de dire que ça sera un mode
envie ou ça sera nulle part c'est pas la
chose que je dis je dis simplement et
pour répondre à Michel Lebeau qui le
sait parce qu'on a discuté avec le
préfet sur ce qui concerne les friches
industrielles nous n'avons pas de friche
industrielle disponible à plus de 20
hectares c'est le seul problème c'est
qu'on n'a pas la surface parce
qu'effectivement ça aurait été la
meilleure des solutions encore une fois
je suis tout à fait d'accord là-dessus
encore que les friches industrielles ne
sont jamais éloignées d'habitation on
aurait eu les mêmes donc c'est une
discussion qui doit qui doit dire qui
doit débuter démarrer avec les habitants
de Magnanville pour leur faire des
remontées d'expérience qu'on a sur des
prisons et notamment sur les nouvelles
prisons qui sont installés ou après une
période de défiance totale et
d'inquiétude parfaitement compréhensible
et parfaitement légitime je ne reviens
pas là-dessus finalement les gens au
final une fois que la prison est
construite s'aperçoivent que ce n'est
pas aussi catastrophique qu'il imaginait
pour toutes les raisons qu'il
craignaient mais ça je sais il y a que
le débat public qui peut le résoudre moi
j'aurais beau dire ça de toute façon
bien mais toi tu es gentil c'est pas
déjà un c'est pas sûr que ta
circonscription même si c'est la joute
et puis tes membres de la majorité
présidentielle donc tu pousses moi je
pousse pas pour manier en ville
spécifiquement je pense que Michel l'a
bien compris moi je suis obligé de faire
confiance au service de la pitch parce
que je n'ai pas les compétences pour les
contrer tout simplement je n'ai pas
l'argumentation pour les contrées et
voilà il se retrouve avec une vraie
problématique
problématique elle est simple laissez
une surpopulation carcérale 161% à la
prison de Bois-d'Arcy ou ouvrir un site
dans les Yvelines voilà après on a quand
même beaucoup travaillé ça fait plus
d'un an qu'on travaille dessus Michel
peut dire avec les copilotage le préfet
a beaucoup écouté les propositions qui
ont été faites à la fois par
l'association de défense de venir en
ville contre la prison et aussi par les
locaux ont été étudiés est-ce que je
suis moi en capacité de vous dire si les
études ont été faites de manière sincère
je pense que oui parce que je ne connais
pas les tenants et les aboutissants d'un
cahier des charges de la construction
d'une prison mais je sais que ça a été
étudié le plus sérieusement du monde par
les services de la pige la conclusion
lors du dernier copine n'est pas
forcément celle qu'on espériez les uns
et les autres on aurait préféré trouver
effectivement plus facile pour
l'implantation ça n'a pas été le cas
je sais pas ce qui va se passer par la
suite mais si Magnanville devait être
tenu au final il faut effectivement et
c'est moi ce que j'ai porté déjà au
garde des sceaux je penche et Michel le
C sur la solution qui est la moins
proche des habitations pour amortir le
choc mais si voilà si s'il y avait si
c'est deux sites qui sont retenus un des
deux qui doit être retenu moi j'opterai
effectivement pour le site numéro 2
celui qui a 1 km des habitations
vous aviez une question
pour vous pour nous Miliana est-ce qu'il
y a des avantages à avoir une maison
d'arrêt dans sa ville selon vous oui ça
rapporte quand même un petit peu
d'argent ça rapporte
oui beaucoup d'argent pour la ville ça
rapporte des emplois ça rapporte pas mal
de choses et puis l'état paie toutes les
infrastructures c'est à dire que toutes
les infrastructures vous avez besoin
pour construire cette prison et pour y
aller de manière sécurisée tous ces
projets là toutes ces choses-là sont
payées directement par l'État ce n'est
absolument pas la charge de contribuable
et ça rapporte pas mal d'argent je me
souviens plus vos manières ville combien
c'était mais c'est une somme assez
conséquente donc voilà mais ça vous
pouvez mettre tout ça en avant c'est
compliqué pour pour les gens parce que
eux leur appréhension c'est je vais voir
finalement des repris de justice
circulaient dans ma ville même s'ils ne
font que passer pour aller à la prison
ou revenir et on a peur
et sans pour rien faire contre ça on a
peur des la prison des gens qui vont se
présenter des gens qui vont venir
visiter comment ça être organisé donc il
faut que les services de la pige au
moment où la concertation publique va
s'ouvrir que ça vise la pige explique
bien précisément comment ça se passe
pour que les gens voient toutes
connaissance de cause si leur crainte
sont vérifiées ou si leur crainte sont
un petit peu
fantasmés j'aime pas le terme mais en
tout cas trop importante par rapport à
la réalité
merci beaucoup alors juste on est pris
par le temps donc en quelques mots
monsieur lebout qu'est-ce que vous avez
justement quelque chose à répondre par
rapport à ce que vient dire monsieur
Midienne par rapport aux avantages aux
compensations qui sont peut-être aussi
bénéfiques pour la commune c'est pour ça
que je voulais me permettre d'intervenir
bon je suis pas tout à fait en accord
avec Bruno William là-dessus les
avantages et les inconvénients il y a
beaucoup plus inconvénients que
davantage et sur les questions
financières sachez que c'est pas la
municipalité qui en prend les fruits
c'est la communauté urbaine étant donné
qu'on est géré par la Communauté urbaine
sur l'ensemble des compétences et donc
sur le foncier c'est la communauté
urbaine moi je ne toucherai on avait
fait un calcul à l'époque c'est la piste
qui nous l'avait fait mais c'est peanuts
quoi c'est 100000 euros par an sur le
budget de la commune donc ce qui veut
dire que il y a rien je dis sincèrement
qu'on a plus d'inconvénients et sachez
quand même que la présidente de la
Communauté Urbaine même si certains les
auditeurs pourraient dire parce que on
va toucher beaucoup plus à la cufo parce
que elle est complètement contre ce
projet là et elle elle s'est positionnée
contre un projet de construction d'une
maison d'arrêt sur le territoire de la
Communauté Urbaine voyez donc c'est pas
la question financière qui a un impact
pour nous mais je tenais à le préciser
moi ce que je souhaite sincèrement et
puisqu'on est pris par le temps c'est
qu'on continue cette concertation je
suis d'accord avec Bruno millième il y a
eu une concertation avec les avec les
élus je rappelle quand même que la
grande majorité des élus se positionne
contre la construction de cette maison
d'arrêt sur les terrains de Magnanville
et notamment un des premiers
responsables politiques de notre pays le
président du Sénat qui a écrit au
ministre de la Justice qui s'est
positionné et qui a écrit au préfet pour
le dire que il y avait une incohérence
totale par rapport à ce que portait
l'État pour la sur la construction d'une
maison d'arrêt à Magnanville donc moi ce
que je souhaite c'est qu'on poursuivre
cette concertation je le dis devant vos
auditeurs je suis prêt avec un certain
nombre d'élus à continuer à essayer de
trouver des sites sur des friches
industrielles parce que je pense qu'on a
la capacité là c'est le deuxième
désaccord que je porte avec avec Bruno
Millenium mais je pense qu'on a la
capacité de continuer à travailler sans
remettre en cause le travail de la pige
je le dis qui a fait un excellent
travail je leur ai dit je pense
continuons à travailler continuons à
travailler avec les élus de proximité et
je pense qu'on trouvera quoi qu'il en
soit même s'il y aura toujours des des
du compte pour du compte mais quoi qu'il
en soit on trouvera une solution à la
construction d'une maison d'arrêt qui
doit nous permettre aussi comme le
disait Bruno millième de réduire la
surpopulation carcérale voilà et bien
merci beaucoup à vous deux d'avoir
accepté notre invitation merci Michel
leboux que donc je le rappelle vous êtes
le maire de Magnanville et Bruno
mignonne je le rappelle vous êtes le
député de la neuvième circonscription
des Yvelines on espère que ce temps aura
permis à un certain de noter les
spectateurs de faire le point sur ce
projet d'installation de la prison à
Magnanville et on poursuit cette édition
avec une page culture
[Musique]
et on ouvre cette page avec de nouveau
invités Véronique Ithurbide bonsoir
alors comment ça va bien et vous-même et
bien très bien le week-end prolongé
était bon excellent super et ben comme
chaque mardi on vous retrouve pour les
insolites des informations qui ont
peut-être échappé à l'attention de nos
téléspectateurs vous nous avez concocté
quoi ce soir vous voulez un petit ou
trois sujets alors on va parler des
chevreuils et de problèmes débrouillés
on va parler de la tombe du compte
Robert de Montesquiou qui est à
Versailles et je vous expliquerai
pourquoi on va en parler et pour
terminer un concert insolite qui a lieu
à la table du roi qui est au cœur de la
forêt de Rambouillet merci et ben on en
reparlera un peu plus amplement dans
quelques instants dans le 7 8 mais juste
avant on va parler du château de
Breteuil avec vous Jean-Emmanuel Charo
bonsoir alors vous êtes administrateur
du château de Breteuil avec vous on va
parler des activités et des animations
que propose le château alors on est
actuellement en pleine période de de
congés scolaires ou de vacances
scolaires comment s'est passé cette
première semaine le temps n'était pas
très clément mais on a eu du monde
malgré les températures un peu fraîches
beaucoup de familles beaucoup de
grands-parents qui viennent avec les
petits enfants qu'ils ont pendant les
vacances scolaires et il y a beaucoup
d'animations en Breteuil pour les
enfants tous les contes de Perros il y
en a 8 qui sont mis en scène dans les
dépendances il y a la conteuse tous les
jours à 16h30 il y a l'atelier de Sophie
c'est un atelier de confection les
enfants font les petits travaux manuels
et puis bien sûr il a visite intérieure
du château avec les personnages de cire
de Grévin c'est tout à fait vivant
ludique pour petits et grands et
d'ailleurs le prochain rendez-vous c'est
aussi le 14 mai vous proposez un compte
musical donc le Chat Botté à 15h30 à
l'Orangerie il y aura un compte musical
qui a été mis en musique par Nicole Bern
c'est le chat botté qui sera donc chanté
par une chorale d'enfant c'est très très
mignon très qualitatif aussi
très bien il y a notamment un escape
game qui a rouvert et sur quoi porte
justement le thème de cette escape game
le prince de Galles en 1912 est en
séjour au château de Breteuil et ça ça
réellement passé le prince est venu
pendant 4 mois chez les breteuils mais
le jeu c'est que une femme de chambre du
Château a entendu des bruits des rumeurs
quelqu'un voudrait à tenter à la vie du
prince de Galles et ce serait un
terrible incident diplomatique si le
prince de Galles était assassiné lors de
son séjour en France chez le marquis de
Breteuil donc la femme de chambre va
réunir une petite équipe d'enquêteurs et
les enquêteurs vont devoir pendant une
heure et demie de jeu résoudre des
énigmes pour découvrir qui veut attenter
à la vie du prince de Galles et donc
déjouer ses projets d'attentat
autour de la table
c'est tout à fait avec le finalement
le château est aussi ouvert durant les
jours fériés c'était le cas hier pour le
1er mai mais ça sera aussi le cas le 8
mai prochain le 8 mai le jeudi de
l'Ascension le lundi de Pentecôte on est
ouvert tous les jours toute l'année
voilà même le 1er janvier et comme vous
le disiez le 1er mai effectivement alors
il y a des animations le 14 mai donc ce
compte musical il y aura aussi une
démonstration par le Chef Olivier
Berthet dans les anciennes cuisines du
château une démonstration de confection
de gaufres et de crêpes à l'ancienne il
y a aussi le 21 mai dimanche 21 mai
inspectacle plusieurs spectacles il y en
a trois dans l'après-midi de danse
baroque essentiellement accès autour des
danses de carnaval de Venise voilà donc
avec des musiques évidemment du 17e 18e
et le très beau costume et les danses et
puis le point fort du mois de mai c'est
il y en a deux en fait le jeudi de
l'ascension des démonstrations d'esprits
artistiques avec les lames sur scène qui
sont une association qui championne du
monde quand même pour la création de
spectacles
voilà ils sont très fidèles à Breteuil
ils viennent trois fois par an animé un
après-midi dans le parc en faisant une
démonstration de de spectacle de cape et
d'épée alors évidemment cette année
d'Artagnan est très à l'honneur donc ils
vont promouvoir encore plus ce
personnage illustre ce héros illustre
et au grand et les parents et les
grands-parents ça plaît vraiment à tout
le monde et c'est pas que pour les
petits garçons et les petites filles
adorent évidemment aussi parce qu'il y a
des il y a des dames qui manient l'épée
le fleuret avec des grandes jupes etc
enfin comme à l'époque des Trois
Mousquetaires et petit garçon comme
petite fille peuvent tout à fait
s'identifier à ces héros
donc ça c'est le jeudi de l'Ascension et
puis l'autre grand point fort
reconstance reconstitution historique
aussi c'est le dimanche de Pentecôte
donc le 28 mai où là nous faisons pour
la quatrième année de suite une grande
journée 1900 donc le château revit son
épopée et son heure de gloire du de la
Belle Époque
cotisait grands sont complètement
plongés dans cet univers de 1900 où le
château veulent Marc Breteuil Henri de
Breteuil à l'époque recevait tout le
gotha notamment Edouard VII mais
recevait également toutes les lites
littéraires et Marcel Proust qui a sa
chambre à Breteuil ceux qui sont déjà
venus le visualisent bien son personnage
de cire dans une des chambres du Château
et puis il y a l'actrice Réjane et puis
il y a le créateur de mode Poiré enfin
voilà on rencontre au cours de cette
journée du dimanche 28 mai on se plonge
complètement dans l'époque 1900 en
rencontrant tous ces personnages et tout
le château est habillé décoré comme en
1900 et par mi tous ces rendez-vous
lequel a le plus de succès
l'escrime a beaucoup de beaucoup de
succès la démonstration des crimes
artistiques et la journée 1900 puisque
là il y a quand même beaucoup beaucoup
plus de personnages costumés dans tous
les lieux du château les communs aussi
les jardins les étages partout on
rencontre des gens costumés en 1900 et
puis chacun à son petit rôle donc il y a
beaucoup de petites scénettes pour cette
journée 1900 voilà il y a des artistes
beaucoup de choses à découvrir bien
merci Jean-Emmanuel Charo on espère
avoir attiré l'attention de nos
téléspectateurs sur les activités que
propose le château et bien je le
rappelle vous êtes administrateur au
château de Breteuil situé à Choisey Lyon
poursuit cette page de culture avec les
insolites de Véronique
et on commence avec cette information
insolite des chevreuils ivre mais oui
mais gênez-vous alors on est au
printemps ça ne vous a pas échappé et
qui dit printemps dit bourgeons qui dit
bourgeons du chevreuil le chevreuil
adore les bourgeons alors autant les
serres il y a aucun problème il mange de
l'herbe autant les chevreuils sont très
friands de bourgeons alors qu'est-ce qui
se passe
ils peuvent en manger jusqu'à 2000 par
jour je sais pas comment on a pu compter
ça mais c'est un chiffre que j'ai vu
alors il se battre excusez-moi du terme
et et si bourré de sucre un bourgeon et
ce sont des ruminants donc les bourgeons
restent dans leur penses voilà et au
bout d'un moment ça fermente et qui dit
fermentation dit alcool qui dit alcool
dit vrai voilà donc on peut trouver en
ce moment des chevreuils avec des
comportements pour le moment étrange un
peu un peu berlué un peu perdu qui
peuvent aussi se retrouver dans un
jardin ou irré dans les rues de un
village etc et alors si en plus ils ont
avalé des bourgeons de Bourdaines qui
est un arbuste
pas très haut dos et raffole pourquoi
parce que il y a le sucre du bourgeon
mais il y a aussi dans la sève un
produit psychotrope imaginez-vous donc
ça fait beaucoup alcool et drogue je
vous apprends rien donc c'est pour bête
mais pas du tout droit non non c'est le
site c'est le signe et il faut savoir
aussi qu'au printemps c'est les
chevreuils les jeunes de l'année
commencent à quitter leur moment à
s'émanciper donc c'est un peu la fête et
et voilà parfois le résultat donc si par
malheur vous
croisez croiser alors si vous le croisez
tellement de malheur mais bon si il est
coincé dans votre jardin m'étonne la
prochaine pas parce qu'un coup de sabot
est vite arrivé est-ce qu'il a l'alcool
gay l'alcool mauvais on ne sait pas
appeler la maréchaussée à savoir les
pompiers ou les gendarmes qui viendront
le récupérer et le remettre chez lui
après les fesses s'estompe assez
rapidement rassurez-vous et après si là
par malheur vous
vous êtes en voiture et vous tamponnez
un chevreuil voilà qu'est-ce qu'on fait
alors imaginons la bête blessée sur le
sur le bas-côté vous appelez encore une
fois la gendarmerie et l'ofb normalement
viendra s'en occuper l'Office français
de la biodiversité voilà pour voir ce
qu'il faut faire de cette pauvre bête et
si terrible malheur mais ça peut arriver
la bête est tuée rebelote on appelle la
gendarmerie on donne son nom et soit
vous l'emportez dans votre coffre soit
vous trouvez quelqu'un qui en a l'usage
et qui va venir le chercher ou alors
vous essayez de le tirer sur sa parcelle
là comme ça pour que la nature fasse son
son œuvre aider des charognards bien
évidemment ça vous est déjà arrivé au
château de Breteuil alors
je connaissais le l'ivresse des dieux au
bourgeons ça oui oui des chevreuils ce
qui est amusant on en a eu un pendant le
confinement qui est rentré dans le parc
qui se promenait alors évidemment il y a
plus de visiteurs il était tout seul il
se promenait et il est tombé dans les
douves et dans les je sais pas si vous
savez nous avons des dents blancs alors
les dents blancs regardez cet étrange
cousin n'avait jamais vu le chevreuil
qui nous avons quand même indiqué le
chemin de la sortie mais il revenait
tous les jours il avait envie de
compagnie un cheval est rarement seul
c'est ça qui est bizarre donc il y a pas
d'eau dans les doubles
informations oui alors ma deuxième
horreur information pardon qu'on
consiste à en fait c'est une photo que
j'ai vu sur internet qui montre une
tombe dans un état de délabrement un peu
cassé à l'abandon et voilà c'est l'atome
de qui de du comte Robert de Montesquieu
qui est un Versailles alors tout à
l'heure on en parlait à vous parler de
Proust par exemple voilà on va y venir
exactement voilà Robert de Montesquiou
c'était un dandy poète un peu insolent
qui est fait partie des amis de Proust
et de Sarah Bernhardt par exemple et on
pense d'ailleurs que Proust sans son est
inspiré pour son personnage du dans la
recherche du temps perdu et ce fameux
compte de Montesquieu à la fin de sa vie
épithé Versailles il avait acheté un
pavillon qui appartenait un écuyé du
rôle Louis XVI il la restaurée il
habitait avenue de Paris donc bien
évidemment lui et son compagnon son
compagnon
Gabriel itouri un argentin et mort avant
lui donc il lui a aussi des gonna érigé
un monument funèbre sur lequel il a mis
en son honneur très très grande statue
qui s'appelle l'ange du silence qui est
assez connu qui vient du château Vitry
c'est c'est montesquik qu'il avait
acheté donc après une fois décédé d'un
côté si tu rejoint son son compagnon et
en fait cette statue qui a disparu
mais en fait quand on se renseigne ce
sont les services de conservateur du
conservation du du cimetière des gonna à
Versailles qui l'ont prise car elle
était tombée d'où cette espèce cet
aspect un peu délabré et qui la
restaurateur est donc rassurons-nous
elle va être bientôt refixée à son poste
c'est une très bonne nouvelle en
quelques secondes comme on a pas trop le
temps on va terminer avec la troisième
information un concert vous voulez que
j'aille très vite allez alors c'est un
concert qui se passe le 13 mai vous en
avez déjà parlé à voilà ça s'appelle
c'est à la table du roi la table du roi
c'est une table en pierre qui est au
confoin de cette route dans la forêt de
Rambouillet table du roi c'est la Clusaz
j'imagine sur la table pour suivre ses
chasses ce qui avait une vue à 360
degrés on l'appelle aussi la table du
débotté parce que c'est la clé cavaliers
les dépit à terre et son restaurant
alors là il va y avoir un concert
classique donc en pleine forêt avec
notamment Olivia gay qui est une
violoncelliste et c'est le 13 mai on
part à pied des étangs de Hollande et
c'est l'association lips art qui a qui
l'initiative de ce concert alors
maintenant il nous reste à chuter
qu'aucun chevreuil ivre ne vienne
déroger ce moment voilà bah écoutez
merci beaucoup
pour toutes ces informations très
insolites dans le département et vous
nous les faites découvrir chaque semaine
et bah merci beaucoup et puis maintenant
c'est l'heure d'ouvrir une page sport
[Musique]
et on ouvre cette page sport avec vous
Michael et le midoro et on commence par
du football c'était le match à ne pas
manquer ce week-end dans le championnat
de National de le deuxième le Racing
Club de France recevait à Versailles
l'équipe de Rouen en première du
classement retour sur cette rencontre et
qui s'est soldé par un match nul à
montage de xavijamin
une ambiance des grands jours ce samedi
29 avril au stade montboron de
Versailles le Racing Club de France
deuxième de Nationale 2 recevait le
leader Rouen des milliers de supporters
ont répondu présent pour soutenir leur
protéger un premier côté deuxième de
base et puis le Racing c'est un club
historique c'est normal il faut que
bonne ambiance voilà c'est une ambiance
exceptionnelle c'est la première fois
qu'on ramène autant de monde franchement
ça va être un match de foot là c'est une
finale là c'est calme c'est clairement
dans cette ambiance de feu les deux
équipes tentent de marquer mais ne
trouvent pas la faille dans cette
première période le score à la pose 0 à
0 la première période elle était c'était
très très serrée c'était un match
vraiment fermé les deux équipes étaient
très bien en place donc il y avait pas
il y avait pas beaucoup d'espace voilà
on le savait hein on savait que ça
allait être un match compliqué en
seconde période le match ne s'emballe
pas le Racing aurait peut-être pu
bénéficier d'un penalty sur cette action
mais l'arbitre ne dit rien en fin de
match les joueurs locaux pensent
s'arracher la victoire sur cette frappe
mais les filets ne trembleront pas score
final 0 à 0 un résultat qui arrangeront
les Normands restent leaders je pense
qu'il y avait la place notamment sur la
deuxième mi-temps où il y avait
plusieurs situations on aurait dû mieux
jouer le coup et on avait la possibilité
de pouvoir
voilà pour ouvrir le score après
l'Euro ils étaient venus pour chercher
au minimum un match nul donc ils sont
pas beaucoup livrés vous voyez sur la
fin il s'est gagné du temps sur les
touches sur les dégagements voilà on
sentait que le match nul c'était c'était
ce qu'il cherchait tout n'est pas perdu
pour le Racing Club de France il reste
quatre matchs d'ici la fin de la saison
pour accrocher la première place la
prochaine rencontre est programmée ce
samedi 6 mai sur le terrain de
Saint-Malo
[Musique]
toujours en National de l'AS Poissy nous
répond plus quatrième défaite de rang
pour les pissèques et cette fois-ci ils
ont perdu sur la pelouse de Vannes 14e
du classement sur le score de 1 but à
zéro au classement l'assy et 7e avec un
bilan de 12 victoires 5000 et désormais
9 défaites depuis le début de la saison
ils sont à 18 points du Racing Club de
France et on va maintenant parler du
rugby dans cette page résultat plaisir
c'est qualifier ce dimanche à domicile
pour les phases finales de Fédérale 2
les plaisirsois ont battus chez eux
assez facilement en barrage d'équipe 2
Saint-Claude grâce à une très grosse
première période des images de Julien
Leroy un match à quitte ou double pour
plaisir ce dimanche 30 avril les
plaisirs recevaient cinq lots du comité
de Franche-Comté en barrage de fédéral 2
une confrontation qui se joue sur un
match en première période l'enjeu semble
avoir galvanisé les ziginoises déroule
et mènent 24 à 0 en seulement 22 minutes
de jeu il géreront cet avantage jusqu'à
la pose 27 à 3 à la mi-temps
on fait une très très belle première
mi-temps
on est quand même à 27 3 à la mi-temps
mais bon il y a quand même trois actions
où on doit vraiment se correr et on fait
vraiment des
erreurs techniques qui sont vraiment
évitables et ça c'est dommageable quoi
parce qu'on aurait pu le tuer le match
plus largement après un mi-temps les a
pris à la gorge tout de suite on marque
en 10 minutes il y a 14-0 on marque deux
fois voilà on a calmé leurs ardeurs tout
de suite et après on a enchaîné quand on
joue comme ça dans l'avancée en général
ça se passe bien au retour des
vestiaires plaisir continue sur cette
dynamique et marque un essai dès la
reprise malgré un relâchement et trois
essais de cinq lots des Illinois se
qualifient devant leur public score
final 37 à 23
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là on est super content parce que c'est
la première fois que le plaisir passe
les phases finales le premier tour les
barrages on a fait une super première
mi-temps avec beaucoup d'intensité je
pense que c'est là qu'on gagne le match
après bon ça a été plus haché il y a eu
un carton rouge en face donc l'arbitre
voilà peut-être un peu compensé mais on
est fier d'être passé contre une équipe
qui était quand même très rugueuse très
heureux de la victoire c'est une
victoire qui valide le travail de
l'année car on aurait été vraiment très
déçu de pas passer ce barrage au
prochain tour de ses phases finales les
joueurs à fonderont Saint-Priest dans un
match aller-retour premier match ce
dimanche 7 mai à domicile pour les
plaisirs en attendant les joueurs
peuvent savourer
[Applaudissements]
motiver pour cette année justement on va
revenir sur votre passion vous avez
commencé la moto il y a 5 ans d'où
est-ce que vous est venu cette passion
comment est-ce que vous avez commencé
alors ma passion est venue d'un jour où
j'ai vu Tom Pagès
en freestyler à la télé j'ai dit à mon
père papa je vais faire ça et du coup
j'ai dû convaincre ma mère pendant une
longue année et puis j'ai réussi à me
lancer oui comment ils ont réagi
justement
avec cette nouvelle passion qui est qui
est né au départ mon père était pas ça
le dérangeait pas plus que ça parce
qu'il avait déjà une moto pour aller au
travail et ma mère aimait pas trop ça
donc était un peu elle avait elle avait
un peu peur et du coup ils vous ont
quand même soutenu pour la suite ah oui
bah maintenant tout le monde est à fond
et aujourd'hui comment est-ce que vous
conseillez justement les études et votre
passion pour la moto déjà la moto je
peux pas en faire le soir
après les cours du coup j'ai le temps de
faire mes devoirs après je fais du sport
quand j'ai le temps et puis sinon la
moto c'est le week-end et mercredi
après-midi quand j'ai pas trop de
travail alors c'est un sport assez
difficile il y a beaucoup de casses
comment vous gérez justement ce côté
dangereux dans ce sport alors j'aime
j'aime le risque et donc bon après si
habitude mais c'est vrai que les
premières fois à chaque fois c'est ça
c'est étendu
les niveaux émotion c'est
possible
je me cassais l'épaule la cheville les
trucs comme ça ça pas du rassurer votre
mère non elle commence à avoir
l'habitude je crois mais la blessures
c'était où dernière blessure c'était cet
hiver à berchères-les-pierres et je me
suis cassé le cartilage de croissance de
l'épaule
l'année dernière vous avez gagné
plusieurs courses en 85 cm3 et quelques
podiums en catégorie 125 cm3 vous avez
le sentiment de progresser alors oui
l'an dernier j'ai vraiment énormément
progressé et franchement ça me rend
super heureux
qu'est-ce que vous avez fait progresser
justement dans vous j'imagine beaucoup
travailler vos techniques comment ça se
passe alors oui c'est ça déjà je fais
beaucoup de stages avec mon coach et
comme ça on travaille la technique et
aussi le rythme c'est très important le
rythme et puis l'endurance parce que
c'est quand même sur 25 minutes une
course donc faut tenir 25 minutes il y a
des séances de musculation justement
alors
mon âge parce que c'est pas un autre
encore mais du renforcement
et même des exercices car pour le cardio
et le fait d'avoir intégré le collectif
France enduro kids est-ce que ça aussi
ça vous aide à passer un cap à franchir
un cap à progresser et c'est un
collectif avec seulement 15 pilotes oui
c'est ça donc c'est 15 pilotes qui ont
été choisis par la Fédération et c'est
ça nous aide vraiment parce que c'est un
coach en dehors d'une autre qu'on a
toute l'année qui a été choisie donc qui
est très bon dans la discipline et qui
nous donne des techniques ou d'autres
façons de passer des obstacles
et depuis le mois de janvier vous avez
aussi le statut de sportif espoir
national qui vous a été attribué par le
ministère des Sports est-ce que ça c'est
quelque chose qui va vous aider dans
votre carrière alors oui ça m'aide
énormément parce que il y a des courses
ou je dois partir le jeudi ou le
vendredi parce que c'est à l'autre bout
de la France et du coup avec avec ce
petit papier je peux je peux dire à mon
école que enfin j'ai le droit de partir
pour faire ma compétition et c'est quoi
vos rêves justement dans cette
discipline mon rêve c'est d'en vivre et
de partir aux États-Unis parce que aux
États-Unis c'est énormément récompensé
les sports dangereux comme ça et
qu'est-ce qui vous reste à faire pour y
aller justement aux États-Unis et bah
pour aller aux États-Unis il faut
travailler travailler rouler et puis
c'est possible oui c'est possible mais
il faut qu'il y ait quelqu'un des
États-Unis qui viennent nous chercher
quoi et c'est quoi le sentiment de vos
parents justement sur votre envie de
partir aux États-Unis
je pense qu'ils sont plutôt fiers après
bah c'est sûr que on vous voit aux
Etats-Unis du coup pour les compétition
ce sera que du travail faut donner tout
ce qu'on a quoi et alors justement en
parlant d'avenir c'est quoi le programme
pour vous dans les prochaines les
prochaines semaines alors dans deux
semaines je fais championnat de France
de cross country donc c'est une course
qui est très très longue donc 1h15 et
une deuxième course de 45 minutes dans
la même journée et après j'ai le
championnat de France d'endu Rocky dans
un mois je crois MERCI Tom Smith d'être
passé dans nos studios pour nous parler
un peu de votre passion en tout cas nous
on continuera à suivre votre carrière et
votre passion de depuis nos studios de
tv78
on va continuer à parler de sport et
cette fois-ci on va parler de baseball
direction Montigny-le-Bretonneux les
Cougars ont rendu ce weekend un hommage
à compagnie coûtons décédé en octobre
dernier la mémoire de l'ancienne
président du club de baseball était
célébré ce dimanche 30 avril au complexe
sportif Jean maréchal à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux à l'occasion du
match contre Rouen une plaque
commémorative a été révélée pour honorer
la mémoire de celle qui avait porté les
cougars en première division un
reportage de Julien le roi un hommage
pour saluer une figure emblématique du
sport une montant lors d'un match à
domicile contre Rouen l'équipe des
cougars commémorait la mémoire Dany
Couton ce dimanche 30 avril au complexe
sportif Jean maréchal cette ancienne
vice-présidente de la Fédération
Française de baseball softball a été à
la tête des cougars entre 2008 et 2018
engagé investi elle faisait monter
l'équipe locale en Division 1 pour la
saison 2017 c'est quelqu'un qui est
resté à la tête du club pendant très
longtemps qui a su le développer aussi
pour être le club qu'il est aujourd'hui
donc oui en tant que nouveau président
bon ça c'est un défi et puis aussi c'est
une source d'inspiration pour pour aller
plus loin et pour présenter le club
encore plus haut en 2019 Annie couteau
recevait la médaille d'argent de la
Jeunesse et des Sports pour son
investissement dans la vie associative
de Montigny-le-Bretonneux le stade des
cougar porte désormais le nom de
l'ancienne présidente décédée en octobre
2022 c'est vraiment une image pour le
club c'est quelqu'un vraiment de
formidable donc on avait besoin de faire
cette hommage ça m'est arrivé après des
déplacements où on rentre tard de la CAN
nous laisse une chambre pour dormir que
vraiment impliqué dans le club à 100%
moi ça fait 20 ans que je suis dans le
club et je la connais c'est c'est la
maman du club Annie elle était là au
terrain quasiment à tous les matchs
importants assise dans les tribunes avec
son flanc qu'elle faisait pour tous les
matchs pour honorer sa mémoire une
plaque commémorative a été dévoilée à
l'endroit où elle avait l'habitude de
s'installer dans les gradins une plaque
pour ne jamais l'oublier
et sur le terrain est-ce que les cougars
l'ont emporté
Bretonneau ce dimanche et cougar ont
fait deux gros matchs qu'on trouve en
mais il conseille de deux défaites face
au dernier champion de France les scores
des deux matchs de dans la première
partie c'est un dans le second match ces
résultats n'arrangent pas les 50 chinois
mais ils ont toujours autant d'ambition
pour cette saison on écoute le président
de l'équipe au micro de tv78 on sait
qu'on peut le faire donc on est vraiment
on est vraiment tous les tous les
joueurs sont remontés à bloc pour pour
aller gagner ces matchs et pour faire en
sorte que on joue les play-offs cette
année et on va maintenant parler d'un
autre sport américain le football
américain à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
les Templiers d'Élancourt ont concédé
une nouvelle défaite à domicile face au
Diables Rouges de Villepinte ils se sont
inclinés 26 à 15 au classement les
Templiers sont pour l'instant dernier de
leurs poules avant leur dernier match de
la saison contre les Vikings de
Villeneuve-d'Ascq et un mot de basket à
présent on va prendre la direction de
Trappes dans le championnat de National
3 les Trappistes se sont inclinés 68 à
67 sur leur terrain contre l'éveil
sportif d'or une équipe dans le ventre
mou de la poule F au classement le scrap
50 ans limite à la 9e place sur 14 à
deux journées de la fin du championnat
ils ont un bilan de 12 victoires et 12
défaites et on termine avec du handball
dans le championnat de National 2
féminin Montigny-le-Bretonneux a perdu
ce samedi soir sur le terrain de
builly-les-mines le score 30 à 28 malgré
les 10 buts de ligne Montaine Maja
velcovich l'ASMB est cinquième du
championnat une journée de la fin du
championnat de terminera pas dans le top
4 du classement et on va suivre bien sûr
avec attention leurs saisons merci
beaucoup à Mickaël pour ces actualités
sportives c'est bientôt le moment de
terminer cette émission et juste avant
je vous propose de jeter un dernier coup
d'oeil à la météo
[Musique]
et le temps de mercredi 3 mai sera au
diapason avec un soleil dominant sur
tout le territoire les températures sont
de 9 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie et Houdan
et Rambouillet et 10 degrés à Versailles
dans l'après-midi le soleil restera au
beau fixe au niveau des températures il
fera 18 degrés à Versailles et
Mantes-la-Jolie et 19 degrés à Houdan et
Rambouillet et demain nous fêterons la
Saint Philippe et la Saint-Jacques et
voilà l'émission touche à sa fin merci à
vous d'avoir été avec nous je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée sur TV 78
prenez soin de vous
[Musique]